one of the most wicked teachers in the
history of Hogwarts Dolores Umbridge is
a fascinating villain and the woman who
played her Imelda Staunton is a
versatile and talented performer but
what happened to the actress after
leaving the franchise he is what
Staunton has been up to since Harry
Potter Imelda Staunton didn't join the
Harry Potter films until the fifth
installment the order of the Phoenix but
she was the perfect choice to play the
multi-layered character of Dolores
Umbridge as a new Defense Against the
Dark Arts instructor a saccharine pink
cloud professor is only there to
dissuade students from actually learning
this forces Harry and his friends to
create an illegal study group so they
can teach themselves to ffensive spells
if that wasn't bad enough
Umbridge also tortures her students and
in one scene she even gets a little slap
happy with Harry despite the fact that
she's driven out of Hogwarts by the end
of Harry's fifth year
Umbridge appears during the second to
last installment of the film series
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 in classic Umbridge style she's
back to her old ways of abusing power
fortunately how he manages to disguise
himself and best her once again with a
mix of wholesomeness arrogance and
cruelty stolen turns pitch perfect
performances on bridge left an
unforgettable mark on the series after
her run in the Harry Potter movies it
seemed logical for stolen turn to
transition into other blockbuster films
and eventually she found a way into a
few hugely successful Disney projects in
2010 Staunton joined Tim Burton's
adaptation of Lewis Carroll's classic
novel Alice in Wonderland the film even
features a few of Thornton's Harry
Potter co-stars including Alan Rickman
Timothy Spall and Helena Bonham Carter
as well as Thornton's husband Jim Carter
she only has a few short lines as a
talking flowers but Staunton gives her
thorny characters some serious
personality and she comes out smelling
like a rose
Staunton also appeared in Disney's 2014
antihero tale Maleficent which stars
Angelina Jolie as a seemingly evil witch
who cursed Aurora better known as
Sleeping Beauty stolen some plays a
character named knock grass she's one of
three Pixies who take human form and
stay by Aurora's side until she becomes
safe from elitism clutches staunton
later reprised her role in the 2019
sequel Maleficent mistress of evil
thoughts of might not have physically
appeared on-screen in her next big
project but her role was an incredibly
vital one in 2014's Paddington stolen
provided the voice of Aunt Lucy who
remains off screen for most of the film
but still manages to give an emotional
backbone to the entire narrative
Paddington spends his childhood with his
loving on Lucy and don't call pastuzo it
was voiced by Michael Gambon you might
remember him as the actor who played
Albus Dumbledore opposite Stanton after
pastuzo tragically dies Aunt Lucy sends
Paddington to live in London where he's
adopted by the quirky and kind brown
family in Paddington - the little bear
embarks on a mission to bring our Lucy
to London to live with him in the Browns
despite many struggles he eventually
succeeds and Staunton briefly reprises
her role for some of the film's most
heartfelt moments the same year that
Stanton made her first appearance in the
Paddington series she took on an
emotionally charged and resonant project
called pride the film based on a true
story is about a faction of London's
lgbtq+ community but bands together to
support miners during the 1984 British -
strike though the two groups seem to
have very little in common the lgbtq+
community raises money for the miners
creating a campaign known as lesbians
and gays support the miners
Staunton played real-life activist
Safina headon who was part of the
woman's support group and strike
committee throughout the film but
there's no denying that Staunton gave a
truly powerful performance Staunton
earned a BAFTA nomination for Best
Supporting Actress and the film itself
got a nod at the Golden Globes for Best
Motion Picture and the comedy or musical
category + pride featured Staunton
acting alongside yet another Harry
Potter veteran Bill Nighy who appeared
in the Deathly Hallows Part 1 after
years on the big screen
Staunton took on some television roles
but true to form for the talented
actress she wisely chose high-profile
projects that brought her even more
acclaim in 2007 and 2009
Staunton appeared in Cranford and its
sequel return to Cranford a story of a
small town were widows and the married
women lead happy fulfilled lives within
their community Brantford featured
Staunton as Octavia pole
one of the more gossipy residents of the
town she was joined on the show by her
husband Jim Carter and once again her
old Harry Potter cohort Michael Gambon
the year 2012 brought Staunton even more
critical success with HBO's original
film the girl
told the dark lurid story of Alfred
Hitchcock and this enduring obsession
with the leading lady of the birds tippi
hedren Staunton played Alma Reville
Hitchcock's long-suffering wife and
screenwriting partner her performance
earned her nominations for another BAFTA
and a Primetime Emmy Award after the
success of the original series it seemed
inevitable that Downton Abbey will get
its own movie and in 2019 the long
rumored film finally hit theaters it
focuses on a visit from King George the
fifth to the Crawley estate imelda
staunton husband Jim Carter reprises his
role as Carson while she plays Maude one
of Queen Mary's ladies-in-waiting the
movie premiered to positive reviews and
that also allowed Staunton to reunite
with her Potter co-star Maggie Smith who
played Professor McGonagall are we going
to kiss I'm glad you want to kiss me but
quite what you said when I last heard
from him something you'd like to say it
yeah oh there are several things I would
like to see the actress who played the
Laureus Umbridge isn't just in the claim
star of stage and screen
in 2006 Imelda Staunton made news when
she was named an Officer of the Order of
the British Empire ten years later she
earned the title of commander of the
British Empire both thanks well work in
the Dramatic Arts now it seems that
storm will take her world ambitions to
the next level
according to Variety in the BBC Staunton
will play the part of Queen Elizabeth in
the fifth and final season of the crown
we can only be thankful that the Laura
Sun bridge never achieved the power of
the throne check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite actresses are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]